hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today i'm
going to be reacting to
tay k the race i don't know
i've never heard it i was requested to
do this song by one of my fans so don't
forget
in the comments below comment what song
you want to hear me do
now also do comment if i got the
analysis right wrong what are your
thoughts how'd i do
and finally don't forget subscribe
subscribe
subscribe i've said it before i'll say
it again i'm 24
i live at home
[Music]
um okay so got my starbucks today too
he's saying it looks like he's trying to
beat a case
i'm guessing this means some sort of
court case maybe it's for robin someone
i don't
we're i'm gonna continue
[Music]
so it sounds like he's got a diverse
range of interests when it comes to like
boot i heard him say he wants noodles
every day which is
you know good also i think he said
chick-fil-a or fish fillet
both good options honestly like he's
like interesting cause he looks like
he's like
16 to me and he's like waving around
this gun
so i i don't know i'm gonna continue
shoot a [ __ ] boy in this [ __ ]
face we think we could get up but you
don't wanna go
that way get away gotta
[Music]
okay so um it sounds like he's partaking
in some illegal activities
i don't really understand what he's
talking kind of fast um he mentioned
he wants to make a girl dance like
michael jackson um
michael jackson did some wholesome
dancing so i think that's okay
honestly in terms of what you'd have her
you know
dance to i'm i'm good with that honestly
i was trying to get the packing get the
packing you get raw for refreshing
[Music]
so it sounds like if you cross him then
you're going to be turned into like past
tense so i think like he's a that's a
threat
okay so if you cross him you might die
like there's there's some bad stuff that
could happen
i was trying to beat
[Music]
[Music]
so he said that he's trying to be to
kate so there's some illegal activities
going on actually let me let me listen
to this part one more time
you can see it in my face [ __ ] a beat i
was trying to be the case
so he's saying like i will shoot you
like you can just see it
in the way that i look that i'll shoot
you i'll do it
i'm not scared but i ain't beat that
case [ __ ] i did the
[Music]
oh i don't know racism he's talking he
keeps talking about a race like what is
he racing to is it like a street race
so some observations about the video he
looks very young
like he looks too young to be like
waving around a gun
talking about how he's trying to beat a
case like
you seem kind of too young for that
honestly observation
number two there's some sort of race
going on i'm
thinking like it could be some sort of
street race
but maybe that's like what the race oh
maybe it's because
he's racing to beat the case like it's a
race because he doesn't he wants to beat
the case
there weren't a lot some of the videos
there's like a lot of people but
it just seemed to be him and a couple
buddies so it didn't seem like he had a
lot of friends maybe he has a more
normal amount of friends like me
like he has a tight tight-knit circle
honestly
if you agree with my reaction comment
below did i get it right did i get it
wrong
should i do it again what do you guys
think also comment what video i should
do next
like this video and subscribe subscribe
subscribe do not forget
subscribe to my channel please please oh
please i will talk to you guys
next time bye